un nuevo episodio de violencia en mexico
los chapos miembros del cártel de
sinaloa y el grupo los mets chicles
protagonizaron un motín penitenciario en
ciudad juárez que dejó dos muertos a
tiros y cuatro heridos de bala tras los
disturbios en el penal los misiles
arrasaron la ciudad mataron a nueve
civiles e incendiaron locales entre las
personas que fueron
asesinadas por este grupo delictivo se
encuentran cuatro personas que estaban
afuera de un local en la avenida
ejército nacional en un en un
establecimiento comercial haciendo un
control remoto que pertenecen a la
estación mega radio las autoridades que
aún no han revelado que causó el
enfrentamiento informaron que seis
presuntos miembros de los mets chicles
fueron detenidos por la policía local
con ayuda del ejército y la guardia
nacional
entretanto varias zonas de ciudad juárez
quedaron desiertas algunas universidades
cancelaron las clases
y la cámara empresarial local pidió al
gobierno que hiciera más por combatir el
crimen organizado por su parte el
presidente del país azteca condenó estos
asesinatos porque se agredió a la
población
[Música]
civil inocente
de este
como una especie de represalia
estos crímenes se produjeron tan sólo
dos días después de que la violencia se
desatará de forma similar en los estados
de jalisco y guanajuato cuando el
ejército mexicano irrumpió en el lugar
donde estaban aparentes líderes de dos
grupos criminales
desencadenando enfrentamientos y quema
de vehículos y negocios